on the mount 32 year old left-hander
patrick corbin
nasty on 85 the slight beast
corbin sets the kick in the pitch
and a swing and a miss on the slider in
the dirt pereira puts the tag on riley
and corbin strikes him out to end the
inning getting max breed on the mound
facing robles escobar and soto
there's a beautiful curve ball robles
took that and freed has his first
strikeout one away
right back where that came from it got a
piece of free ozzy dive slings to first
and got his man
what a play by albies that caught max
freed on the thigh it looked like as it
made its way back through the box and a
great play to erase escobar it kind of
just barely grazes them i think it's
fine but what a play by ozzy i mean that
was a strong throw
over to first base great play the 2-2
pitch here it is
he went
soto was out on a check swing
max free throwing his fastball in the
first inning struck out a pair soda
didn't like it no score second inning in
dc that's two away here at the top of
inning number two and it'll bring up the
catcher travis darno on his left hand in
the pitch swinging a slow chopper up the
third base line fair ball keyboard
charges in out of the out of the grass
and then the off-balance throw across
the body in time to bell to retire the
size max digs in he's six for 13 at the
plate since the all-star break
2-0 on the way
that is lying down the left field line
of fair ball he's done it again kicks
off the wall in pursuit of hernandez
gets to it and as he sends it in max
freed is going to be satisfied with a
single
i hope his left thumb is okay because
that jammed him really bad and
it just happened to stay fair
but another knock
so breathe down at first here's ozzie
corked into center misjudged and over
the head of robles freed around second
he's chugging for third bubble on the
warning track free to round third helmet
flying he will score and the braves get
a gift it's one nothing
boy a huge misread by robles out on
center field i guess he saw ozzy out
front you see how he got out front on
that pitching not but you could hear it
he squared that ball up and good job by
max here it's one good thing max got a
lot of speed and wash look he knows max
is athletic and he takes every advantage
of that and sends him
it's up to freddie freeman to get that
right in from third base with two down
freeman on the ground that's gonna sneak
through for a two out hit
freddy freeman's 64th rbi that's a
biggie
it's two nothing atlanta after being
held hitless last night just takes this
one right back up the middle and the way
they play the shift on them it's an easy
rbi
this is tres pereira the washington
catcher
another breaking ball more soft contact
catcher running glove flip from ozzy
albee's he's made a couple of good plays
today
ozzy's so good at this play playing the
shift a little bit had to run long ways
it'd have been close if he took his time
and got it out of his glove to see what
happened but makes this just look too
easy
so victor robles trying to bust up the
perfect game here in the bottom of the
fourth
nobody covering first except victor
robles
nice bunt we had a feeling it was going
to be on this pitch but not a bun look
at that victor robles
perfect button that's all you got to do
is
beat freddie freeman into the bag no
chance
here's juan soto
right field
back is solaire
and he can only play the karum row blaze
heads for third sono into second
after missing tying the game
by not too much
and the nets in business here in the
fourth so here is josh bell and the
pitch to josh curveball shot up the
middle base hit center field robles
scores soto is being held at third as
heredia fires a strike in one hop to the
third base side of the plate
so the nationals on the board rbi single
for josh bell
ozzy plated the first run of the night
see what ozzie can do with the payoff
here it is
swing and a drive that's wallop to deep
left that ball is in the bullpen
ozzy albies golfs another homer out of
the ballpark number 22 and the braves
extend the lead and four straight days
now
for the home run for ozzy all diesel
on the ground and into left field that's
a base hit solaire a big turn around
second hill slam on the brakes
freddie freeman's two for two and the
inning continues that's the third
atlanta hit in the fifth inning dansby
two groudouts today 22 rbis for him
after the all-star game the 2-2
line drive base hit left field is gonna
score those two runs
dansby comes through for atlanta he's
scorching hot and the braves add on
four runs in the fifth inning
here's hernandez
here's the pitch hernandez grounds to
base into left field robles gets the
wave and he's headed toward the plate
duvall comes up firing and it is offline
robles slides in and he scores
holding it second is belle on the rbi
single for yadiel
hernandez first and second one out of
walking a hit batsman brings up swanson
nothing into the pitch
swaying and a fly ball hit hard toward
the braves bullpen dansby golfs another
one out
wow a five rbi day for dansby swanson
and that's a back breaker atlanta has
scored nine
he's homered in two straight
back to the top of the order to ozzy
albies and what does he have in store
for us now
two balls and no strikes pitch all the
way to ozzie and he sends one out to
right fiona base hit
just over the leaping luis garcia who in
the shift was in shallow right
jack had to make sure he was going to
lay down it did and he took off the
third base
but now ozzy is a double shy of the
cycle
1-1 ground ball out the third glove by
the third baseman key boom to second for
one to first four two run will score
peterson comes across the plate makes it
a 10-2 lead for the braves one down base
is empty for dansby swanson
swinging another shot off the bat of
swanson a line drive to left that one's
gonna go
it's another home run for dansby swanson
it's a six rbi day man are the rbis
coming in bunches for him
he had a seven rbi game earlier this
year
stay hot son they will drag him kicking
and screaming to the charter after the
game tomorrow
adam duvall is in there
with an 11-2 score today the pitch swing
at a high fly ball by duvall that one's
back toward the bullpen that one's at
the wall that one's gonna go
back-to-back homers adam duvall has his
26th of the year
bombs away for atlanta ga in washington
tonight
one more out will do it brings riley
adams to the plate
pitch on the way to adams got him
looking strike three
and the braves have won nine of their
last 11
as they whipped the gnats tonight by a
final score of 12-2